well uh now for the main event of the
evening uh again the resolution reads
between now in 2035 electric vehicles in
the consumer Market will disappoint
environmentalists by remaining a product
bought mainly by the well-healed
minority speaking for the affirmative
Mark Mills Mark please come to the
[Applause]
stage speaking speaking for speaking for
the negative uh yeah yeah good yes
indeed uh speaking for the negative
Rosario funo Rosario please come to the
stage Mark uh you have 20 minutes to uh
speak for the resolution and take the
podium take it away
mark
thank you Jean thank you for the
opportunity it's delighted to be here
with a fellow Canadian
Rosario we can hear good this is better
all right so if we could imagine a time
a time machine that could bring to New
York City a 19th century American the
odds are that the one thing that would
seem the most amazing about our time for
that 19 Cent citizen would be the
proliferation of the personal automobile
big buildings big cities roads nighttime
illumination would all be imaginable but
and different looking greater in scale
but the one thing that would is
radically different about Modern Life
and daily life is the convenience and
freedoms that come from a car and it's
uh obviously it's probably in your head
that that ha 19th century citizen would
probably be puzzled by people staring at
glowing rectangles in their hands in in
fact the personal computer and the
personal car are co-equal in their
transformative impacts historian Leo
Marx put it well when he wrote and I
quote to speak of the impact of the
automobile upon society makes little
more sense than to speak of the impact
of the bone structure on the human body
close quote the centrality of the car in
Social and economic structure of our
society is evidenced by how citizens
have voted with their pocketbook a car
is the single most expensive product
that 98% of consumers ever purchase over
90% of American households own or have
access to a car average household
spending on personal Mobility is a
second biggest expense after mortgage or
rent and there's nothing whatsoever to
the Trope that the rising Generations
will abandon automobiles a recent MIT
analysis found Millennials exhibit no
difference in preferences for vehicle
ownership and in fact drive more miles
per year than Boomers did and as for Gen
Z's the share of cars bought by that
cohort has increased five-fold in the
past five years finally to finish sort
of the framing of why cars matter let's
consider what used to be called
telecommunity you know zooming remote
working especially following the Epic
Urban Exodus caused by the destructive
lockdowns of 2020 surveys show that
those lockdowns accelerated an already
underway trend of a huge swath of
Americans moving to suburbs or rural
areas it's a trend that invariably leads
to Greater need for cars and distances
driven now come politicians and
activists in a dozen states and the EPA
via a creative exercise of regulatory
Authority with plans to ban the right to
purchase a car with an internal
combustion engine the kind of car that
98% of Americans still own and the kind
of car that 98% of average incom
Americans still buy the goal of the bans
is not we're told to deny any citizens
the ability to own or afford a useful
car instead as everyone knows it is in
service of the goal to cut carbon
dioxide emissions by mandating the use
of the so-called zero emissions electric
vehicles EVS for all the process of
transitioning to EVS for everyone
everywhere we're also told will be
painless because EVS are inevitably
taking over the entire automobile Market
because they are it's said simpler
better and easier to use and cleaner and
now the orwellian named inflation
reduction act promises a gush of money
to induce that transition let's
stipulate the obvious one does not need
subsidies and mandates to convince
people and businesses to buy products
that are inherently radically better or
cheaper but assuming that that
legislation isn't reversed by a future
Congress that inflation creation act
will deploy two to three trillion
dollars to subsidize an energy
transition half of which will be for EVS
and related
infrastructure you can buy a lot of OB
ience with that kind of money and with
so much money combined with political
mandates and PR momentum we should not
be surprised to find no automaker daring
to avoid genuflecting to the Grand
Vision of an all EV future but money
can't buy a change in the laws of
physics and underlying engineering
realities the ostensible inevitability
the enthusiasm the subsidies and the
mandates for EVS are all anchored in
three claims that EVS will radically
reduce Global CO2 emission
that EVS are cheaper and easier to fuel
because well you just plug them in and
that EVS will soon be cheaper to buy
than conventional cars because they're
inherently
simpler all three of these claims are
flat wrong start with a core claim that
they're simpler yes conventional cars
have complex thermome mechanical systems
engines and automatic transmissions are
made from hundreds of components
although they're made with a very simple
fuel system a tank with with a liquid
and a one moving part pump EVS inversely
have a simple motor made from a few
parts however the EV fuel tank is a
complex electrochemical system made from
hundreds sometimes thousands of Parts
thousands of welds includes a cooling
system structural systems sensors Safety
Systems and a boatload of Power
Electronics EVS aren't simpler they're
just differently
complex the illusion of EV Simplicity
has relevant to the strike underway by
the United Auto Workers Union EVs do not
entail less labor to build but instead
shift where the labor takes place the
data show that overall there are about
80 people employed per thousand
conventional cars produced each year
Tesla the world's biggest EV maker for
now employs about 90 people per thousand
cars produced per year it seems strange
well consider just the labor to make the
two different drivetrains again take
Tesla and especially its Trend setting
Nevada gigafactory where public data
show that there are about eight people
employed per thousand EV drivetrains
that's Electric Motor Plus Battery the
combined employment at a conventional
engine and transmission Factory is just
four people per thousand drivetrains
that's the inverse of the EV labor and
EV simpler argument and there's more to
the labor story realities that have
implications for emissions and costs for
that we look Upstream to the primary
metals and materials that are sent to
the factories to fabricate the vehicles
steel and iron make up about 85% of the
weight of a conventional car that
Upstream supply chain requires less than
one person per thousand Vehicles
produced meanwhile most of the weight of
an EV is found in more exotic so-called
energy minerals from copper and aluminum
to obviously lithium and also nickel
Cobalt manganese and rare earth like
neodymium that Upstream supply chain for
EVS employs roughly 30 people for every
th000 EVS of course all that labor is
elsewhere since the mines and refineries
are not in America although some of them
are in my homeland in Canada but before
turning to the cost and Emissions
implications of the Upstream realities
we need to address the claim that EVS
are simpler to fuel it's OB excuse me
it's obvious that the imagined all EV
future requires on-road fast charging
first the total labor to deliver the
same energy to EV fueling stations is
actually greater then it is for the
gasoline infrastructure something that
will necessarily ultimately impact costs
but setting that aside the LIE of the
simpler to fuel is in the nature of
electrical engineering to fast charge
batteries the so-called superchargers
offer instead of overnight fueling 80%
charge in about 30 to 40 minutes this is
only fast if it's not compared to the 3
to four minutes it takes to fill up a
gasoline tank long refueling times will
translate into to long lines at EV
fueling stations and the need for 5 to
10 times more charging ports than fuel
pumps that won't be convenient it won't
be simple and it won't be cheap each
supercharger costs two to three times
more than a gasoline pump and because
superchargers necessarily operate at 100
times the power level of an overnight
home charger that translates into
staggering requirements for grid
infrastructure upgrades today roadside
fuel stations have the electric demand
of a 7-Eleven but each EV fueling
station will have the electric demand of
a steel mill and highways will need
thousands of them in the enthusiasts
that are either unaware of or profoundly
naive about the time and cost challenge
all that extend their naive to un to the
uh materials demands themselves the
quantities of copper needed for all the
wires and the Transformers that will be
required to replace cheap steel pipes
and tanks and the metal demands for the
electric infrastructure will necessarily
be piled on top of an unprecedented
increase in demand for metals and
minerals to fabricate EVS in the first
place while copper is the long pole in
the tent it's only one of the mineral
challenges the realities of costs and
Emissions for EVS is dominated by a
simple fact a typical EV battery weighs
about 1,000 pounds and it replaces the
fuel and the tank that holds the fuel
that together weigh under 100 PB that
half ton battery is made from a wide
range of minerals including again copper
nickel aluminum graphite Cobalt maganese
of course lithium and to get the
materials to fabricate that half ton
battery requires digging up and
processing some 250 tons of the Earth
for each battery those numbers it's
important to understand are roughly the
same no matter what the specific battery
chemical
formulation and yes that EV tonnage
should be compared to the combined
tonnage of metals and the weight of the
oil to fuel a conventional car over its
lifetime even if you compare those
numbers over a 10-year lifp span of both
kinds of cars the EV still entails a
tenfold greater extraction in handling
of materials from the earth and Far Far
More acreage of land Disturbed and
unfortunately often polluted the
astronomical quantity of materials
needed for EVS has led proponents to
claim that there are after all enough
minerals on the planet and there's
nothing to worry about in anyway they
say we can recycle to reduce the
Monumental materials requirements but
recycling will be Irrelevant for long
time since manufacturers claim correctly
EV batteries will last a decade that
means there won't be anything
significant available to begin recycling
until the early 2030s long after the
world has had to face up to the biggest
expansion of global mining in history as
for the underlying resources to supply
the suite of energy minerals of course
there are enough of all those on planet
Earth and even in America that also is
irrelevant what's relevant is that the
data show that overall the mines that
are operating and planned can't Supply
even a small fraction of the 400% to
7,000 per increase in demand for
minerals that will be needed within a
decade to meet the ban the engine goals
what's relevant is that the Ia the
International Energy agency has told us
that we'll need hundreds of new Mega
mines and it takes 10 to 16 years to
find plan and open a new mine you can as
they say do the math on that the need to
supply astonishing quantities of battery
minerals is also where we find the
problem with the claims for big EV
emissions and cost savings since over
70% of the cost of an EV battery comes
from purchasing the basic materials
needed that means the future price of
EVS is dominated by the future cost of
those basic materials and is dependent
on guesses about the future of foreign
mining in Mineral Industries not the
labor and automation prowess at a
domestic assembly plan and over the past
half dozen years they often cited long
run rapid decline in battery costs has
this has not only slowed dramatically
but since 2021 average battery costs
have risen 20% and so far that's with
ev's still well under 10% of total
vehicle production we are still in early
days of minerals demands and it's with
the acquisition of those key minerals we
find flaw with the core claims for
emission savings the energy used and
thus emissions from producing a pound of
copper or nickel and aluminum for
example is two to three times greater
than for steel the numbers are far
higher for the other minerals
researchers at the Argon labs for
example have pointed out that the
relevant data to evaluate emissions for
battery materials are meager to
non-existent I'm quoting them and that
forces researchers to resort to again
quote calculations based on
approximations end quote that means
every emissions claim is a rough
estimate or an outright guess based on
averages or approximations assumptions
aspirations there are huge variables and
uncertainties in the emissions from
energy intens of Mining and the
processing of minerals used to make EV
batteries and the simple fact is that no
one knows how much CO2 emissions will
decline as materials production Rises to
build more EVs and all of the key
variables in fact point to higher not
lower emissions in the future the energy
used to obtain a pound of metal depends
on the size and nature and location of
the mine for copper that number can vary
at least two fold for nickel by at least
three-fold getting accurate information
is Complicated by the fact that 80 to
90% of all the relevant Minal minerals
are mined and refined outside of the US
and the EU and will be for a long time
regardless of subsidies and since China
refines 50% to 90% of all the world's
Suite of these energy minerals for EVS
it's relevant that its grid is 2/3 coal
fired and will be for a long time there
is a dis honesty at the center of all
the fastel claims about big emissions
reductions from EVS in fact nearly all
studies making emissions claims are
worse than guesses they estimates that
are frequently cherry-pick low numbers
what's really happening Upstream a meta
study of 50 different technical studies
on emissions from EVS found that the
estimates varied by over 300% and worse
that analysis exposed the fact that most
emissions analyses most claims were
based on assuming the use of a small 30
KW battery that's onethird of the size
of the battery that's usually that's
used in nearly all the EVS that are
purchased by most consumers outside of
China you triple the size of the battery
and you triple the Upstream emissions
and you triple the demand and thus price
pressure for the minerals Upstream
minerals missions not only offset the
savings from not burning gasoline but as
the demand for battery minerals explodes
the net emission savings will shrink and
it could even vanish reasonable in fact
even likely scenarios will lead to EVS
causing a net increase in global
emissions and geologists have long uh
pointed out and documented that or
grades have been and will continue
declining for the non the
noncog that means for each new ton of
mineral there's a steady and unavoidable
increase in the quantity of rock dug up
and processed a decrease of just 0.4% in
Copper or grade will require seven times
more energy to access
the copper unlike cars with internal
combustion engines it's impossible to
measure an ev's CO2 emissions and unlike
cars whose emissions are the same
wherever or whenever the car is made or
used EV emissions vary wildly depending
on how it's made and where it's made and
where it's used while self-evidently
there are no emissions while driving an
EV emissions occur elsewhere the
Upstream emissions before the first mile
is driven and also when the vehicle's
parked to refuel it those latter
emissions from the grid are also far
more complex than simplistic forecasts
assume real world emissions from
charging depend on precisely where and
exactly when it's done the refuel
emissions can vary from near zero on a
sunny day in some states in other states
and other times to the same or more than
would have happened from just burning
gasoline in the first place none of this
means that lithium batteries don't
deserve a pivotal place in history its
invention was consequential for many
reason nearly all of which have very
little to do with EVS nor do the
inconvenient complexities of Mining and
grids mean there won't be lots more EVS
in the future today's Fleet of nearly 20
million EVS globally notably half of
which are in Cal burning China that
Fleet will doubtless balloon up tens
more tens of millions more probably
hundreds of millions of EVS on global
roads in the coming decade or two but
even such dramatic growth would mean EVS
will account for barely 15% of all
consumer vehicles that future date and a
far tinier share of Industrial and
Commercial Vehicles the future of EVS in
ecosystems of
Transportation by way of analogy almost
certainly will end up echoing in market
share terms and for similar operational
reasons the role of helicopters in
aviation helicopters offer very
different and in many applications far
more useful even essential features
compared to Conventional fixed wi
aircraft that's why there's a very
significant $60 billion a year Global
Market for helicopters but that's only
15% of the overall Global aircraft
Market helicopters like EVS are very
useful for a very large number of
applications but one would no more
expect all Aviation to use helicopters
than for all drivers to use EVS the
realities of the physics and Engineering
in geology means that activists pushing
for an all EV future by 2035 will be
disappointed they'll be disappointed not
just by high costs and cry emissions
reductions but more importantly but by
what will eventually emerge in terms of
consumer and voter unhappiness and
behavioral if not political resistance
to the high costs and the inconveniences
imposed on the single most expensive in
critical product used by the
overwhelming majority of
citizens thank
you
Rosario Rosario fortuno for the negative
take it away
Rosario ladies and gentlemen I'm excited
and honored to be here to challenge a
far-reaching resolution which with major
consequences for a time between now and
35 uh 2035 electric vehicles in the
consumer Market will disappoint
environmentalists by remaining a product
but mainly by the well-healed
minority counter to this EVS are are
actually projected to be the majority of
new car sales by 2030 that's 5 years
before 2035 this comes from a multitude
of independent Market sources including
Bloomberg new energy finance and S&P
Global mobility and historically the
adoption rate of transformative
Technologies is massively
underestimated my objective in this
Oxford style debate as has been
mentioned is to change more Minds than
my opponent Mark Mills my criteria for
uccess is to show that EVS are
accessible and appealing to a diverse
group of consumers if you believe by the
end of my talk by the end of this debate
that EVS will be commonly bought by more
than just the wealthy you must vote
against the
resolution my opponent just conceded
that the resolu he just conceded the
resolution when he said that hundreds of
millions of EVS will be sold in the next
10 years the resolution is not that
internal combustion engine or ice
Vehicles will consider Contin continue
to be driven in 2035 I agree they will
be but so will EVs and EVS will be
driven by a non-trivial portion of the
middle class in fact it seems that my
opponent as recently as this past July
agrees with that in his paper titled
electric vehicles for everyone The
Impossible Dream he stated and he stated
basically this in his opening speech EVS
are a practical and appealing new
category for many drivers and the world
will see tens of millions more EVS on
the roads even without government
mandates today I'll be focusing on the
following Universal factors driving
electric vehicle adoption one
convenience and performance two safety
three Environmental and Cultural
incentives and four affordability and
availability I'll take this on from a
free market perspective discussing why
people want EVs and how they will get
them I'm going to focus primarily on
Tesla for three reasons they dominate
the US EV Market with more EV sold than
all other automakers combined in 2023
Legacy automakers are absolutely lagging
in profitability and technology and
Tesla is setting the standard for
competitors in the industry so anyone
who wants a slice of the pie will have
to copy them the first major factor is
convenience and performance I'm going to
start with a little personal story while
preparing for this debate my Tesla drove
me autonomously 400 m from Calgary to
Saskatoon in the dead of winter Inus 30
before I left my car was automatically
preheated and fully charged in my garage
my car knew I was going because the trip
was in my phone's calendar and the car
routed me automatically through
superchargers on the route full
self-driving enabled me to multitask
giving me the invaluable gift of
productive time on the way I crafted my
debate arguments and reviewed Mark's
paper while my car handled all aspects
of driving safely this is completely
unachievable in ice vehicles and will be
for the foreseeable future why because
autonomous driving is a win or take all
technology and Tesla is winning by a
huge margin and Tesla only makes
EVS this story helps debunk some of the
myths uh that are prevalent about EVS
that my opponent had mentioned uh the
first one is that range is a downfall of
EV uh of EVS with battery technology
advancements the median EV EV range in
the US actually increased from 73 mil in
2011 to over 2 50 mil this year and the
Tesla Model 3 offers 333 mile range at
only $
47,2 40 before any
incentives myth number two is that EVS
aren't good in the winter well Tesla's
thermal management is a GameChanger
maintaining optimal battery temperature
and preheating the cabin before you
drive advanced heat pumps preserve range
in Ultra cold temperatures and features
like regenerative braking a low center
of gravity and dual motor traction
control give it the best best snow and
ice performance for any car and to top
it off EVS won't fail to start in cold
temperatures like internal combustion
engine cars myth number three is that EV
charging stations are scarce or
unreliable well there are actually over
50,000 Tesla superchargers globally
today superchargers connect every part
of North America and they add 200 miles
of range in about 20 minutes there are
multiple chargers at every station and
superchargers actually have better
uptime than gas pumps so now that we've
busted some myth myths about EVS let's
turn to the lifestyle benefits that are
making EVS better than ice cars to own
the first one which my opponent glossed
over is at home charging so a simple
drier Outlet or dedicated EV charger for
around $500 and your EV will be charged
and ready to go daily you'll never have
to go to a gas station again the average
American commute commutes around 30 mil
per day so with a single charge that
that'll last you more than a week but it
doesn't matter because your car will be
fully charged whenever you need it let's
talk about energy Independence
liberty-minded individuals like myself
May value this by combining a Tesla with
rooftop solar and a home backup battery
You Free Yourself completely from
government utilities and the volatile
oil and gas
Industries let's talk about some
unmatched features of electric vehicles
so my Tesla has a mindbending
acceleration of 0 to 60 and under 3.1 1
seconds in my model 3 it has dog mode
which keeps my pets comfortable during
errands it has smart summon where the
car locates and drives to me
autonomously in parking lots which is
especially useful in bad weather and
Sentry mode with multiple cameras
protecting my car from theft at all
times my Tesla had none of these
features when I bought it but it now has
all of them thanks to overthe a updates
which make the car better the longer you
own it but the game changer is FSD the
future of travel is high volume lowcost
autonomous ride sharing think Uber
without drivers this is not a luxury
it's a transformative industry changing
technology Tesla is far ahead in
autonomous driving technology and they
only make EVS so only EVS will have it
in summary EVS especially Teslas are the
superior choice not just an alternative
to ice Vehicles because they offer
unprecedented benefits over ice cars
including convenience performance and
lifestyle which is defining the
expectations of what a vehicle can and
should do let's talk about safety safety
is a key factor that's influencing
consumer vehicle choices Tesla's safety
record is unparalleled Teslas have the
best crash test scores of any vehicles
on the road according to the IHS the
model the model Y is the safest vehicle
that money can buy Beyond crash tests
Tesla offers a comprehensive Suite of
Crash preventing safety features which
are standard in every Tesla features
like Advanced automatic emergency
breaking an autopilot with
industry-leading Lane keeping and
adaptive cruise control let's talk about
statistics here from Tesla's own Fleet
data Teslas are 4.3 times safer than the
average American driver when autopilot
is enabled this translates to an AC
accident frequency for the average
American driver in their own car of an
accident every 120,000 miles but with
Tesla's autopilot you have an accident
only every 500,000 miles but that's just
autopilot full self-driving or FSD costs
$200 per month or $122,000 for Lifetime
access FSD drives you to your
destination without manual intervention
your car does the driving from door to
door the driver must remain attentive
for now but the regulations will change
and this is only available in Teslas the
impact on safety is massive autonomous
cars never get tired they never get
distracted they never get impaired
McKenzie research states that autonomous
vehicles will reduce vehicle fatalities
by up to 90% according to the US
Department of Transportation there were
nearly
43,000 fatalities in motor vehicle
crashes in 2021 the implication here is
that thousands of lives will be saved
annually in summary Tesla's goal is not
just to mitigate but to prevent
accidents entirely setting new safety
benchmarks for the industry
this challenges the notion that EVS are
only appealing to the affluent they're
appealing to everyone who values
safety let's talk about environmental
concerns despite being a controvers
controversial topic the desire to have a
more environmentally friendly vehicle is
one of the many Market drivers for the
adoption of EVS so I'll address it there
are myths surrounding the environmental
cost of battery production and EVS but
it is a fact that that EVS are a lower
emission option than ice Vehicles over
their lifetime and importantly the
emissions from EVS are not blowing in
your face from the car in front of you
there are many studies supporting lower
emissions and EVS a carbon brief
analysis in 2022 study by Ford Ford and
the University of Michigan showed that
EVS have lower lifetime emissions in ice
Vehicles even in Coal intensive
countries but what about battery
production and renewable energy Tesla's
gigafactories are massively reducing
emissions for manufacturing through
renewable energy as the energy grid
evolves the environmental case for EVS
only strengthens a reliable and ethical
supply of raw materials is also a
concern that Tesla is already addressing
lithium nickel iron and Cobalt are all
essential for Ev batteries but Tesla's
master plan part three which is
available online outlines Tesla's plan
to build factories to extract lithium
and other critical minerals directly
from Desert s sand these factories will
be online well before 2030 and there are
more than enough rare earth metals in
the US to meet all the demand for
EVS in summary the environmental
incentives are legitimate Market driver
and supported by data and technological
advancements as cleaner energy becomes
more prevalent and the environmental
advantages of EVS will only
grow let's talk about affordability and
availability as it turns out e are
already affordable and they're scaling
rapidly a key reason for this is Elon
Musk and major Chinese EV manufacturers
economies of scale lead to technology
maturation which leads to cost reduction
Bloomberg new energy Finance reports a
91% reduction in the average cost of EV
batteries from 2010 to 2023 the cost per
kilowatt hour has fallen from $1,160 in
2010 to only $100 per kilowatt hour in
2023 in the near future Tesla's 4680
cell and battery pack are projected to
reduce costs by an additional
53% over the next 5 years by 2027 we'll
have a 500 mile range EV for an
inflation adjusted
$25,000 in fact Tesla has a new
gigafactory planned in Mexico where
they're going to produce this
$25,000 EV as early as
2025 in summary Market Force
and technological advancements are
making EVS increasingly affordable but
what about affordability
today well actually the selling price of
a Tesla is already below the median
price of a car in the US in 2023 which
is $
48,8 according to Kelly Bluebook here's
a real world example we'll compare the
Tesla Model y with the second
bestselling car in the US today the
Toyota Rav 4 the Rav 4 has a lower base
price
but long-term costs favor the model y a
similarly speced model Y is actually
$3,500 cheaper before any tax credits
the model Y is
$43,900 a Rav 4 with similar trim
leather interior heated seats all-wheel
drive is
$47,500 now let's talk about fuel versus
electricity costs there are Savings of
thousands per year with the model y
today due to lower electricity costs
comparing the least expensive gas state
to the most expensive electricity state
which is kind of unfair it cost $19 to
get 300 miles of range in Hawaii in a
model Y which is the most expensive
electricity state but it cost $25 to get
that same 300 miles of range in South
Carolina in a
RAV which is the least expensive gas
State When comparing averages EVS blow
it out of the water it's $9 to travel
300 mil in theel model Y versus 2750 to
travel 300 M in the Rav 4 that
translates to $8,300 in savings over 10
years let's talk about maintenance costs
Teslas require less maintenance that's a
fact no oil changes long-lasting brakes
due to regenerative braking and fewer
moving Parts in electric motors and
Teslas retain their resale value longer
because battery packs are designed to
last over 500,000 mil as as a personal
anecdote I owned and operated an all
Tesla ride sharing company which I
founded in 2015 and we had vehicles in
the fleet with over 400,000 kilm that
were still on the original battery pack
that's over 300,000
miles 10 year the 10year total cost of a
model y comes out to
$325 if you sell it at the end of its
life versus the Rav 4 at $
38,6 so the model y life cycle cost is
over
$6,000 lower than Rav 4 and the time
value of money is also considered in
these calculations which makes it even
worse for the Rav 4 um in summary the
model Y is a better financial decision
both initially and over the long- term
when considering total life cycle costs
and the time value of money what about
availability today Teslas are actually
the easiest car to buy you can order
online with Apple pay and have the car
delivered directly to you there's no
dealership markups or haggling and
here's the kicker remember how the Rav 4
is the number two selling car in the US
model Y is actually the number one
selling car not EV the bestselling car
period both in America and globally in
2023 the technology adoption curve
doesn't lie initial adoption is slow but
accelerates as technology matures new
technologies are reaching 80% market
share faster and faster and EVS are no
exception
Tesla delivers 1.3 million EVS in 2022
and they're on track for 2 million this
year with new factories and scaling
existing existing ones that'll lead to 5
million Teslas per year by 2025 and 20
million per year globally by 2033 this
easily meets the projected us demand of
8.5 million EVS assuming 50% of new car
sales are electric Tesla also has the
highest profit margin of any automaker
in the industry and it's worth noting
that Tesla is the most American
automaker in the world even the
batteries are made in the US Tesla only
sells four models of cars today two
sedans and two SUVs but the biggest
Market segment in the US is trucks
enters Tesla's cyber truck with over 2
million pre-orders and deliveries set to
begin this year this indicates a market
willing to embrace Innovation even when
it challenges traditional Aesthetics if
you've seen the Cyber truck you know
what I'm talking
about
so let's talk about some broader
industry Trends gas prices are
increasing at nearly 40% year-over-year
traditional auto manufacturers are
stagnating because of a lack of
innovation Union unrest and de
globalization leading to increased costs
the average selling price of ice cars is
increasing every year the number of ice
cars sold is falling globally at a rate
of more than 12.8% per year in contrast
the number of EVS sold globally is
growing by roughly 40 % year-over-year
and the average selling price of
electric vehicles is falling at around
19% per year already over 10% of
vehicles sold globally in 2023 are fully
electric the trend is obvious by 2035
EVS will be accessible practical and
desirable for the majority because they
already are in
2023 futurist Roy Amaro once said most
people overestimate what they can
achieve in a year and underestimate what
they can achieve in 10 years the rapid
growth of EVS is a testament to the
underestimation of what can be achieved
in a decade let's revisit the key themes
that demonstrate why widespread EV
adoption is not just likely but
inevitable first we explored how
convenience performance and lifestyle
benefits of owning an are
unparalleled next we demonstrate next we
demonstrated that Teslas offer offer
safety benefits that are far beyond
World beating crash tests that is is the
transformative potential of full
self-driving or FSD which is already
saving lives with the potential to save
thousands per year we then explored the
Environmental and Cultural incentives
fueling consumer interests in EVS
finally we showed how tesas have already
become affordable to the average
consumer and widely available thanks to
Rapid achievements or advancements in
Battery Technology and economies of
scale driving the point home with the
case study of Tesla's model y the best
selling car in the US and the world the
future of transportation is here driven
by declining costs widespread
availability and unmatchable performance
and features by 2035 EVS will be the
go-to choice for consumers from all
walks of life driven by market forces
and consumer preferences thank
[Applause]
you f five minutes of rebuttal Mark
Mills take it away Mark you want to take
the podium or you want
do it from the chair take it away five
minutes well you are Rosario a Tesla fan
of
course as am I um I admire Elon Musk uh
he's accomplished something that cannot
be explained Away by subsidies alone
although I will point out that a close
to half of the gross profits come from
selling emissions credits to The hapless
other automaker so that's a uh a
regulatory finger on the scale by our
federal government look uh Tesla
self-driving is is fascinating I happen
to agree I think they're ahead of
everybody and self-driving but it is not
true that you can't Implement
self-driving on internal combustion
platforms and it is true that he isn't
making an internal combustion platform
but the tragedy of the commons when it
comes to technology means that this lead
on that likely evaporates far quicker
than his lead on Battery Technology but
your observation that I concede the I
can see the debate by telling telling
our audience that there will be hundreds
of millions of cars in the next couple
decades that are electric powered is not
a concession it's 15% of the automotive
Fleet globally if that maybe 12% and the
same will be true in the United States
the percentages are skewed by China
numbers so I I would forecast something
like the 15 to 20% range for the United
States in in early
2030s which would constitute a minority
and most of those will be in the luxury
Market as they are today right now Tesla
is it has very few models so when it
comes to Total Car Sales the sales are
skewed to the luxury Market the luxury
Market is less than 20% it's about 15%
of total car market Tesla has 75% of the
luxury Market uh which is not nothing
this is why all the luxury automakers
which is the most profitable Market are
desperate to make cars to compete with
him I would say um given where the world
is going in his lead as the others face
bankruptcy because of the uh in uh
imprudent investments in in batteries
and the way they're pursuing it that he
will be the last man standing so that
there will be I think tesel will be
around for a long time but as for the uh
forecast from Bloomberg new energy
finance and McKenzie and that whole
cabal of Consultants uh they are
reliably wrong on most things of these
matters and particularly on this one
because they're all ignoring the
minerals part the minerals part is now
sort of bubbling up in the consultancy
community and and the you know the
chattering classes that worry about
these things in in charge for for their
time for the automakers it is it's just
as one example the copper the copper is
is in fact the long pole in the tent uh
plats uh S&P plats has done an analysis
on this globally and domestically the
world is not going to produce enough
copper by a factor of two to three in
the next 5 to 10 years to produce the
number of EVS that are imagined not the
number of Teslas it's possible Elon Musk
will have a special deal with a Chilean
copper suppliers hard hard to know what
he's done but globally there won't be
enough um copper available to make all
the electric motors all the batteries
and all the uh Distribution Systems I
didn't say and I you and I agree range
is not the problem the whole thing of
range anxiety is silly EVS have plenty
of range they have the same range or
better than most conventional cars the
problem is that as you proliferate the
number of charg superchargers is that to
make the infrastructure and this is just
electrical engineering 101 one the
electrical infrastructure to power
supercharges which are in the 700
kilowatt range uh will cost between 500
billion in1 trillion dollar in the
United States no utilities are currently
planning that infrastructure expansion
to handle a majority of vehicles being
supercharged even if we assume at home
charging about onethird of American
homes have a garage so that more homes
in the wealthy but certainly the
wealthier homes have garages a home
charger produces a power Demand on the
local distribution Loop double the
actual home's overall power
requirements that means that the
distribution Transformers have to be
upgraded there's a shortage of
distribution Transformers and their cost
has tripled in the last five years
because of copper prices so the
California utilities have looked at as
closely and they're obviously worried
that as more homeowners do this
overnight in the wealthy neighborhoods
the distribution Loops grids will not
handle it so money will have to be spent
by someone lastly uh you know the cost
comparisons are are interesting and
important EVS uh do have some cost
advantages but what's being skewed right
now where very few consumers are paying
the full cost of charging the taxes that
are levied on all Road users are not
levied on EV users and no governments
will be happy leaving those taxes uh
carried only by uh the hapless uh
drivers of gasoline cars so those taxes
will move over to electric charges so
the AC symmetries will start to
evaporate and the costs are unavoidably
going to rise on minerals because
there's never been this is true there's
never been industrial policy pushing
this much demand for minerals without a
market response markets will respond but
they'll respond by raising the price of
the
minerals Rosario uh uh you get five
minutes and 25 seconds for rebuttal
because Mark took an extra 25 seconds
sounds
good so I I wanted start talking about
um mining a little bit because that is a
big part of your um your pitch that EVS
will not uh proliferate as quickly as as
many people think because of uh the lack
of raw materials but um one thing you're
overlooking is innovation and and the
ability of the free market to uh meet
demand um and and uh grab uh grab
opportunities um as quickly as possible
so um one of the the solutions to this
issue which I think is undoubtedly going
to happen in the next 10 years is
actually um asteroid mining so um mining
asteroids um could drastically increase
the supply of essential metals like
Platinum lithium and others thereby
reducing costs and the environmental
impact so that's something that
companies like SpaceX are are working on
um and even then you didn't address my
claim that uh Tesla's planning to
extract large quantities of of these
minerals from desert sand and they're
planning to open these factories before
2030 um now there is enough Supply uh
and I don't think you concede or you may
concede this uh in the world uh the
challenge is is actually getting the
supply in America um because a lot of
our the supply comes from countries like
uh Africa um for Cobalt and or not
countries sorry continents like Africa
countries like Uganda and uh also uh
China um however those uh as We Know as
free market enthusiasts um being able to
have the opportunity to purchase
products from those countries is
actually raising those people helping to
raise those people out of poverty so
that is certainly a benefit of um you
know purchasing products internationally
but the truth is that there there is
enough of these raw materials available
in the United States and we can get
these things here if if that's the
direction that the country wants to go
in um and certainly in Canada as well um
and uh the main reason for the 10year
hurdle to build these plants is because
of government um and Elon Musk has has
proven quite a depth at getting around
some of these
challenges um
so wanted to address kind of the
argument that EV charging won't scale um
so that's actually not supported by
current trends in in infrastructure
devel uh infrastructure development and
user Behavior so charging is actually
becoming more convenient
um and faster and the necessity of
garage a garage for charging is a
misconception actually anyone with
access to a parking spot and electrical
pole nearby will be able to charge uh
where they Park their vehicle overnight
with existing technology um even um
street lights can be repurposed uh to
become Chargers if you don't have
anything nearby and and that's not very
difficult um and as I mentioned um the
proliferation of at home charging with
rooftop solar and and batteries at home
are going to mean a lot more people are
going to be free from having to pay the
government for uh Utilities in the
future I think which is a a huge
plus
um trying to think of some of the other
things
that uh that I'd like to
address
um
Yeah you mentioned in your um in your
speech that there are no concrete plans
to man manufacture enough batteries to
proliferate EVS but I mean I know sound
I'm an Elon Musk fan boy give it up uh
Elon Musk the world's richest man has
explicitly stated his life mission is to
accelerate the world's transition to
sustainable energy Tesla has outlined
plans to increase um captive battery
production to 200 gwatt hours per year
by 2024 and three terawatt hours per
year by 2030 and this will more than
meet future Global demand for fully
electrified
Vehicles Tesla's been already growing
production at a pace of roughly 50%
compounded annually for the last 10
years and aims to continue this growth
for the next 10 years there's many
sources for this uh and if Tesla
maintains this growth rate they'll
easily manufacture enough EVS to replace
every ice vehicle on the road um and I
believe that uh Mark had mentioned that
you know 100 million Vehicles won't
replace the the fleet the global Fleet
of ice vehicles but I remind you that's
not the debate like certainly um more
than 50% of vehicles sold um ever to
date are uh not going to be electric by
2030 but more than 50% of the vehicles
being sold at in 2030 will be electric
so I think you just have to look at it
as how how many vehicles are people
buying and compare that to what the
resolution States so people are going to
be buying 50% of EVS in 2030 so I think
that pretty much covers everything thank
you we now go to the uh the Q&A portion
of the evening uh and uh uh those who
might have a question uh yeah well yes
indeed indeed yeah Mark yeah you'll have
your moment
yes indeed yeah I just want to tell yeah
that you can uh line up to ask your
questions and uh but uh then uh both
sides have the option of asking the
other a question at any time and it
looks as though Mark Mills would like to
pose a question to Rosario so would you
pose your question mark I'm posing a
question by way of an assertion though
you and I both like Elon Musk obviously
I hope you own his stock um
I would say the resolution this is not a
question the resolution is not sales
it's the electric vehicles in the
consumer Market um so this a Nuance but
it's a big difference as you know we're
selling a lot of EVS but there'll be a
minor share of the market I'll say just
quickly on you and I are free marketers
we both think markets can respond and
Technology can respond I think it will
by the way I agree with you I think a
lot will happen the problem is I'm also
a realist about what governments do and
and the ability to open minds I don't
care whether it's Elon musk's mind or
anybody's mind is impeded by uh the
state of regulations in United States
and they're getting worse in Canada so
maybe the question is not do we what are
there enough minerals are enough
minerals there aren't enough mines what
makes what makes you confident other
than free market trying to respond that
the West which will be us in Europe you
know North America will actually have
the capacity the political will to
respond because that's what's lacking
we're not going to be mining the
materials because we're not going to let
it happen and we'll be dependent on
China as as we are today so I don't see
evidence for that I'm the last Optimist
I'm hoping it'll happen but I don't see
the evidence for it in the time frames
we're talking
about yeah that's a good question I
think that um what the government does
actually often follows the will of the
the people maybe later so they start
mandating things when they're already
happening um for example so we're
already on this trend and and we can see
that there's extraordinary demand uh for
these Technologies so I think that the
government will be incentivized uh to um
kind of get out of the way a little bit
and allow people to uh exist and uh and
proliferate these Technologies or
they'll get
evicted um I hope you're
right uh moderator's prerogative just
POS a question to rosar
uh when you mentioned uh you sort of
blew my mind slightly when you said well
there'll be Innovation and then you said
well we're going to mine asteroids uh
and uh uh do you feel that the mining of
asteroids is essential to the scenario
that you're wed it to uh you shook your
head all right the mining of asteroids
is not especially important just that
it's something you think we could do
yeah it's it's certainly physically
feasible
now in 2035 yeah between now and 2035 um
especially with spacex's new starship
that they're they're building and going
to be launching like in the next year or
two but um I mean that's not that's not
Central to my argument at all like as uh
as Mark mentioned there there are enough
minerals on Earth that's that's not the
challenge any coming on the asteroids
well I'm I'm I'm I'm kind of a space bug
I love SpaceX more than Tesla in terms
of its reach and achievements but the
the issue of asteroid mining in fact
there's a lot of good technical
literature on this there's there's a 0%
chance we can mine an asteroid in in the
next decade we're going to have a heart
the current Mission which which is being
launched probably on Falon heavy to do
more uh exploration of the asteroids to
look at you know study them is uh not
going to get to the asteroids till after
2030 so we we're a long way away from
mining asteroids the I just one quick
point on convenience of charging the
existence of wires and poles is not the
issue so telephone poles and and uh
light poles are just fine the lights
though are 100 watts and for a even a
modest fast charger you need 100
kilowatts so what you have to do is
upgrade wires and and Transformers to
handle that power level at each one of
those points and that's where the money
comes in it's not technically impossible
it's just a half a trillion dollars to
get enough charge
points response M yeah so it it actually
doesn't matter if the mission is a
accomplished before 2035 it's the market
will price in the massive reduction in
um mineral cost far before it happens if
they see that it's it's coming down the
pipeline so even if the minerals aren't
delivered by 2035 if we know it's about
to happen then the the price of those
those minerals will
drop well the the IMF economists and
others would probably disagree with you
I would too I think the market will
respond as it has over time mineral
prices will go up before they go down
they tend to cycle like all Commodities
there's going to be an a an epic mineral
price inflation before there's a new
Supply it'll have to be sustained price
inflation to lead to the investment in
new classes of mins IMF did a very
important study on this and concluded
that the mineral demands that EV
mandates are putting will cause the
largest inflation in basic metal prices
that the world has seen in a century
even if they're wrong it's still going
to be significant and markets will take
a while these are very slow processes
mining I worked for a mining company
opening mines is very slow it doesn't
happen in a few years and none of the
world's miners are today planning or
announcing plans to invest in sufficient
capacity because I think they don't
believe this is all going to happen
that's why they're not doing it so what
I'm hearing you say is go into the
mining industry invest in mines we have
a lot of questions coming from the
audience uh please uh uh ask a question
ask a question and no need to identify
yourself your question
sir this question is from Mark um how
would you feel if the resolution was
changed to say 2045 2055 how I'm
curious yeah well timing matters see a
2050 2060 but the the pro the reason the
2030 2035 is chosen it's because the
dozen states are going to ban internal
combustion engines by those and two
dozen countries so what really matters
is all all these uh bands and automakers
if they stay in place automakers are
going to believe that's going to happen
and they'll they'll shift and it will
cause enormous dislocations in in
markets um so will there'll be lots of
EVS eventually you bet it will be half
of all all cars uh at some point in the
future entirely possible I mean but
that'll be a world where there'll be
three billion cars not 1.4 billion and
so you'll have maybe a billion internal
combustion engines and a billion five
EVs and that billion internal combustion
engines will use almost as much gasoline
as today's billion four car so it's it
both happen in those time frames so give
it another 25 years and maybe it'll
happen we'll change the debate we'll
come back in 25 years I'll be a little
older then any comment from you Rosario
about that no yeah I just wanted to say
that this debate is about the consumer
market so that kind of precludes the
business uh the business market so like
obviously there's still a huge um demand
for diesel uh trucks and things like
that which you know is another debate we
could talk about how quickly that'll be
but 1.5 billion are consumer Vehicles
1.4 billion consumer vehicles in the
world today and be 3 billion in 20 years
go go ahead sir question a question
primarily for Rosario but also be your
interested in Mark's answer um all of
the market incentives political
incentives
for uh EV demands or demand for EVS
growing the number of
EVS it's based on the premise that CO2
emissions are the primary cause of
global warming that global warming is a
bad thing that Rising atmospheric CO2 is
a detriment to the environment and human
health and so on and so forth yet there
are extremely good reasons to think that
all of these beliefs are not factually
grounded and I'm wondering how likely
you think it is that these myths will
still be widely held by the general
public by 20135 to continue driving all
of these incentives yeah I mean I think
I tried to at least I tried to do this
with my uh opening remarks but I I think
I demonstrated pretty conclusively that
the reason that EVS are are being
adopted is not because of um these
environmental concerns I think people
don't make decisions about things in
their day-to-day lives based on these
large generalizations people make
decisions on the margin so they make
decisions for their family they make
decisions because something is cheaper
or better or provides them more value
than the alternative so I would suggest
that EVS are not accelerating primarily
because of the climate change narrative
but because they're a better alternative
uh compared to internal combustion
engine vehicles and a better choice for
most people comment Mark well is
unquestionably the case that there's a
distortion in the market both by
subsidies and and mandates and that
helps to accelerate it and it's
unquestionably the case in China it's
entirely driven by uh federal government
Fiat behaviors there and subsidies there
as well so that that's unavoidable but
but I agree with Rosario in this and
this is why I oppose the mandates
whatever the reason for the mandates
whether it's climate change or otherwise
I think there's a big market for
consumers primarily wealthy consumers
because the EVS are going to get not
much cheaper and then more expensive but
there's a huge demand for the features
they offer to lots of consumers I mean I
Yer in my study if you look at the US
market there's 300 million vehicles in
the United States as many vehicles
personal vehicles as cars as people and
most two to three car households buy
their second or third car for all kinds
of emotional reasons family reasons
personal Reas and luxury not save the
planet necessarily some virtue signaling
it's a big Market it's probably 30 to 40
million cars that's a lot of cars
especially in the high end so that's why
I'm saying it'll be a high-end dominated
Market even when the climate uh push
fails and it won't fail because people
will capitulate On Believing climate's
an issue I don't believe that it'll fail
because of sub Peak subsidies you just
can't afford to keep traveling trillions
of dollars of subsidies on a market this
big I think that'll end next
question um uh given that uh you're
making predictions about the consumer
market for vehicles by 2030 2035 uh does
the presence of uh nuclear energy on the
grid um does that make an impact on your
time prediction and I have a second
question this debate is about internal
combustion engines versus EVS what do
you guys think of
hybrids uh my gosh I I think we better
pass on that hybrid question maybe talk
about it at the party afterwards but uh
but I guess the nuclear question is uh
uh relevant Mark well I'm a I'm a
nuclear bull uh there's 72 different
kinds of nuclear designs in the pipeline
around the world probably all of them
will work probably half of them will be
commercially viable in the next decade
or so
um but it doesn't profoundly change the
equation in the sense of how how many
people buy EVS it affects obviously the
grid equation how do we make electricity
much better way of spending than on
solar in Wind I'll say hybrids are where
the world's going we can talk about that
later knock that
in that was a hybrid answer that was
inadmissible Mark and uh Rosario do you
want to address the nuclear thing yeah I
mean hbd like I said the the cost of
electricity is a huge driver for people
to choose EVS over gas cars especially
with the cost of fuel Rising
dramatically um and as more nuclear
power comes onto the scene it should
only help serve to lower cost L should
help to lower costs sorry and um
accelerate the transition um and I also
wanted to just touch on on Mark's Point
quickly that the government is heavily
subsidizing electric vehicles so I I'd
written a whole section of my debate on
this but actually it's um it's pretty
clear that the government support for
the oil and gas industry has far
exceeded its support for electric
vehicles so according to a 2018 study by
the Manhattan Institute the electric car
tax credit uh cost the US Treasury about
$670 million a year in contract uh
contrast fossil fuel subsidies and tax
credits the same year cost uh $4.7
billion annually uh with the oil and gas
industry is claiming at least three4 of
that total so Biden got the message they
raised it to 2 trillion for Ev so we're
going to over subsidize EVS now
instead I'd like to hear from both of
you about what you think of the
advancement and the evolution of battery
science it's been projected that we'll
have very very efficient batteries and
they'll be less thirsty than they have
been to date and that's also because the
consumer growth factor that we see in
future sales is that families who drive
in the 25 mile radius 35 Rus people stay
in are most satisfied with that um
efficiency right now but inter city
travel with those car with cars today
are the problem in the current market
for Ev so I'd like to hear about Bing
science and your hope for the future and
what you project for the next few years
because some of the people in that
sector are projecting big advances in
the next few years a big advantage in b
i I think questions address at Mark and
then you Ros you good yeah Mark well the
short range use of vehicles argues for
plug-in hybrids no
uh
but the battery factories that are being
built today and subsidized today are
using yesterday's technology not
tomorrow's Technologies so this would be
an argument against the subsidies and
the grants because if you want Market
competition to work on Next Generation
Battery Technology we wouldn't be
subsidizing yesterdays which is what
what happens when governments get
involved they lock they do lock in
battery science battery chemistry will
get better like all Technologies the
irony is the Headroom in the basic
physics of how much better batteries can
get the electrochemistry versus the
Headroom of much better internal
combustions engines can yet get is much
more capacity to make internal
combustion engines more efficient than
there is to make batteries more
efficient they both can be made far more
efficient but the limits are dictated in
the basic physics of electrochemistry
and combustion chemistry and there's far
far more cap capacities at far less
money to make internal combustion's
engine better but I'd love to see
competition but we're not doing that
we're we're we're not only
disincentivizing more efficient internal
combustion engines we're going to ban
them it will be the Apple car
maybe yeah you want to come in yeah I
definitely do not advocate for bans of
any kind on internal combustion engines
I don't advocate for bans of any kind on
internal combustion engines just to be
clear sorry I I feel like I'm not
speaking loud enough
um you mentioned that
uh sorry could you remind me of uh uh
Innovation and Battery Technology yes
Innovation and Battery Technology
so it's not necessary for there to be
further innovation in Battery Technology
for EVS to continue to proliferate
because the current batteries are
already capable enough for for most
people uh I would say I haven't had any
issues with them but certainly in my uh
Speech I said that by
2025 uh Tesla's 4680 cell which they're
designing with technology but we'll have
a 50 plus% Improvement in terms of cost
per per mile range so certainly those
improvements are going to continue and
even if they don't uh continue at an
exponential rate and they only uh
improve at a slow rate it'll still lead
to a rapid progression of EVS yeah
proliferation
sorry uh hello this is a question uh for
Rosario um so I don't know if you've
seen that most of electricity generation
in the planet is in the first place done
by burning fossil fuels to begin with so
has anyone done the calculation of so
supposing you're T you're charging your
Tesla at home and you're happy because
you think you're saving fossil fuels
you're not really because in maybe some
of it because but most of the energy is
generated by fossil fuels to begin with
for electricity now if you combine
question now so here's what I'm trying
to say wouldn't it be a uh like putting
kind of a nail in the coffin of the EV
industry to tell people look the main
sources of fossil fuels if you add the
amount of fossil fuels needed to mine
raw materials for the Batteries Plus the
amount of fossil fuels required to get
electricity in the first place you
already supersede the amount of fossil
fuels burned by Transportation you might
be just be changing it might be looking
like it's diminishing can I just can I
interrupt sorry we we got your question
that's not that's not accurate use we
got your question I'm sorry that that's
not accurate um I I I went over it in my
um in my speech but it's there's been a
ton of studies done on this and I've
done the math myself and you can I I
have a lot of articles about this on my
website um but you if you look into it
the life cycle emissions of EVS on a on
a coal 100% coal grid so life cycle
meaning from building the EV to driving
the EV for the entire life to retiring
the EV and recycling it are still lower
than the life cycle emissions for
burning a for burning in a gas car
burning oil in a gas car today this is
where Rosario and I disagree because I
when I wrote the paper that I wrote I
looked at about 180 to 200 references
citations probably 100 of them were
studies on the on the analysis of life
cycle emissions this is the core
argument that the that the governments
are making it's has my again my opinion
has nothing to do with the viability of
an EV EVS are are a terrifically great
option for a lot of people but the
studies that are done and published are
are flawed and many of them in fact are
dishonest but they're fundamentally
flawed because they make assumptions
which are not correct so we know there
are ranges of emissions from mining
copper but the when the range is
available and it's welln in technical
data the studies that do the emissions
from making the battery all of them have
chosen the low end of the range not the
mid not the median not the high but the
low end this is true for nickel this is
true for lithium and all the studies
including the ia's own studies show that
all the emissions associated with
excessing minerals are rising as I said
in my opening remarks because of
declining or grades so you need
technology to solve that problem but no
one knows yet what the Technologies are
that will reduce the energy cost of
accessing the minerals so there's
there's a whole uh body of flawed
studies that are being ProMag and used
by Ford by Volkswagen by uh Volvo that
contain data that when you look at their
primary sources have a finger on the
scale of picking low ends of
averages you want to come in Ro yeah I
just I just want to kind of comment and
then pose a question to you mark so like
all your studies that you cited in your
paper as far as I could tell agreed with
me that life cycle emissions are are
lower but you're saying the studies are
flawed which I can certainly understand
um the question would then be like given
that we're progressing towards more and
more Renewables and Manufacturing is
getting more and more efficient would
you agree that likely in the future EVS
will have lower life cycle emissions
than than gas vehicles well the question
is where the future date is because the
what we again the DAT the data show in
the technical literature and the GE
geological literature that or grades are
declining declining org grades mean
digging more stuff so what you have to
then imagine is that those mines don't
don't use diesel powered trucks at some
point and they're going to use battery
powered trucks it's possible but the
those trucks are multi-million dollars
they are not practical with batteries
anytime in the near future so the whole
the whole industry is a fuel fossil fuel
consuming industry 40% of the world's
industrial energy is used in mining and
refining 40% to make all the copper and
lithium and manganese and nickel needed
we're going to have to double the
world's mining industry so the that fuel
will be oil gas and coal it won't be
renewable because the mine sites in in
remote Africa you can't run the Grinders
and Crushers 247 on solar panels and
batteries it's too expensive so it so if
the if the question is can we get there
eventally yes uh if I were guessing a
number 20 30 years some but the decade
time frame that we have available to us
to push this new mining expansion is
going to involve a massive increase in
oil gas and coal use in global mines and
there are mines that we have no control
over we can say we don't want to buy the
copper fine but it's coming from mines
in South America and Africa some of it
will be in Australia and Canada but most
of the expanses are in Indonesia in uh
in Asian countries next
question okay uh I'd like to ask both of
you to address the question of uh
battery fires I mean here in New York
City uh where do you park a car
uh a lot of people parked them in
apartment buildings in the basement or
in garages with lots of
cars uh given the history of battery
fires I I would not want electric cars
parked underneath me some ships have
gone down carrying hundreds of cars
recently after yeah that actually wasn't
caused by the batteries me so the
problem of battery talking about battery
fires I can address this so it's
actually complete myth that EVS um
combust more than uh catch fire more
than gasoline cars um on a per uh EV
basis uh on a per car basis EV batteries
are actually far less combustible than
gas vehicles SO gas cars actually catch
fire far more often than EVs do um and
uh in reality the it it's it's quite uh
quite rare for for EVS to catch fire
rosar rosari and I half half agree maybe
70% V diagram uh at first the data
aren't good enough yet to really know
what the the fire exposure rates are
because I think Teslas are pretty well
made they're really high quality control
and the key with with lithium batteries
is high quality control I had the good
fortune or Misfortune of running as a
CEO of a lithium battery Factory for for
almost a year and learned a lot about
lithium chemistry
safety I think in overall they're comp
they're comparably safe it's possible
engineer lithium cars that are equally
safe I believe
I don't think that's really the issue
for the long run cu the issue will be
quality control and then new Fire
Control behaviors lithium batteries
lithium Burns differently than gasoline
but these are these are manageable over
time and Engineers know how to how to
deal with this I I just think the data
are are weak and what I worry about are
poorly poorly produced lithium batteries
which is why a lot of the fires in
Manhattan with with the bicycle shop
these are cheap Chinese batteries which
have low low quality control and those
can light on fire and the fires are hard
to put out and they're devastating so
it's it's sort of a red herring in one
Sense on the other you got to be careful
where the battery comes from and who
made it so buy Tesla buy Tesla stock buy
a
Tesla next question I'm pimping for Elon
like you
are over the last few decades we've seen
this huge migration into cities I mean
up until coid I would say a lot of the
benefit that we talked about was was if
you have a garage and if you can charge
it at home and whereas it seems like on
the other side the the there's an
infrastructure need in cities is that
taken into account when you make a
projection for to uh for 2035 or is is
that really IR relevant on this time
scale talk about the infrastructure of
uh what what the infrastructure for
charging these vehicles do you need the
the the city population to have these
vehicles or can you just would would
just getting the Suburban people to to
these cars would that matter enough to
city population versus Urban yeah okay
Rosario well I think there's advantages
to having an Eevee in both locations and
actually the amount of additional
charging infrastructure is I think a lot
lower than Mark estimates because most
people are only driving 30 miles a day
so you're not fully charging your
vehicle every day you're going from 80
to 90% kind of thing every single day um
so you don't actually need that
significant uh change in infrastructure
to be able to uh handle the the excess
demand and as more Renewables come
online more localized energy storage uh
we have that more capacity and then also
um Market mentioned about um having to
have all these excess superchargers all
over the place and I I don't think that
that's how it's going to work like
people aren't going to go to
superchargers to charge up like they do
gas stations today they're just going to
have their vehicle charging at at work
or at home while they're not using it um
and then just one more like Vision thing
like if you look at how people commute
like how having an autonomous vehicle an
electric vehicle that can drive you to
work every day will I think make it a
lot easier for people to live uh far
away from where they work because they
could actually work in their vehicle
while they're while they're commuting so
we're having a a conflation of energy
and power and this is not to to digress
into electrical engineering 101 but
doesn't matter how much energy you put
in the battery uh the power levels are
the same so the charger has a power
level the power levels required to do
fast charging even home charging are
higher than the power levels that exist
to serve loads on grids today so the
upgrades I'm talking about are not for
fuel not whether it's solar panels or
burning natural gas it makes no
difference so the challenges are quite
clear in California they have already
decided that grid upgrades are not
adequate to handle most homes having an
inhome charger as for on road Chargers
it's certainly the case it's more
convenient to charge at home plug it in
at night it's not the case that if you
have to drive any distance so you just
have to look at the percentage of
Americans that the number of times they
drive somewhere that requires refueling
that's where the refueling supercharges
have to come in and again the arithmetic
on that National Grid did a study
looking at the assumptions of behaviors
how many people will actually drive some
distance and need to be refueled on the
road those are the behaviors I'm talking
about that will require a half trillion
dollar in distribution upgrades to get
that much power not energy the Power
Systems the size of the Transformer is
required to run run the Chargers th this
is not a debatable point in the sense
that electrical engineering hasn't
change it's there is innovation there
but it's very very slow because it's an
extremely old industry I'd like to just
uh kind of I I I have a degree in
electrical engineering so I I know a
little bit about it um but yeah um you
know home charging can be done with a
120 volt outlet and if you're driving 30
m a day that's that's enough so you can
just plug your car in into any any
outlet and it'll give you um enough
range overnight to do most of your daily
driving but yeah Mark is right the power
uh required for the um the supercharges
is high but Tesla is already scaling
This and like I said they have 50,000
stations globally and and they're
expanding them all the time so we don't
even need utility providers to do
anything because Tesla has the
electrical engineering utility providers
have to put the Power the wires the TR
and the distribution substations to get
the power to his superchargers the
United States has 1 million fueling
ports for gasoline today 1 million even
if you assume you don't need half as
many in in the in the in the future
that's the number of supercharges of
50,000 versus 500,000 to a million is
it's a huge disparity but the as you
know as an electrical engineer that
supercharger is standing there it's 150
kilowatts for a Tesla one you put 10 of
them in a fueling station and it's a
megawatt that fueling station can't
handle a megawatt it's not on Elon Musk
until he takes over a utility and God
willing he does because they need
Innovation too but they have to upgrade
the distribution grades and the problem
is not that they can't do it you and I
know they can do it they're not doing it
and they're not doing it because they
don't have the money and if they start
doing it it will cost a lot of money and
the arithmetic there is not mysterious
it's not subject to much Innovation
because they're Transformers there's
only a dozen companies in the world that
make these distribution Transformers
they use lots of copper so they'll start
demanding copper just when the electric
motors are demanding copper and the
batteries are demanding copper and
that's the doop that's the problem final
question uh it seems that the bottleneck
of raw materials has come up multiple
times throughout the night so I'm
curious given that the median income in
the US is well over the 99th percentile
in the world but there's a global market
on materials my question to mark first
is uh if we were to consider the the
resolution and the consumer market for
vehicles as the United States could you
see electric vehicles dominating in that
market given the purchasing power and
Rosario if
Tesla it's it's really it's just the the
flip side of the same thing in the
global market where we to consider the
consumer Market to mean the global
market even if Tesla dominates in the
United States how how would you see
electric vehicles dominating the global
market we were only talking about the US
in this particular resolution for what
that's worth but then also we're out of
time and so guys uh if you want to
address that very good question your
summation
please do so we now go to the summary
portion of the evening and the
affirmative goes uh first uh and Mark
you want to take the podium you want to
do it from your chair here you what
right here go ahead five minutes of
summary well I think the if we come back
to the resolution which is not about the
sales rate but the number of of vehicles
that are electric for consumers in 2030
2035 there'll there'll be a lot of them
and United States will probably reflect
the world and will be in the 15 to 20%
range which is a huge jump from today's
1% and the rate of increase will whether
we get there or not will be dictated by
what other countries do and whether or
not we we do two things whether the
world produces enough minerals I'll keep
coming back to this because it is
unequivocally the case the US Geological
Survey has done a study on this U
there's been the World Bank has done
studies on this the UN has done stud
there's dozens of studies looking at
Mineral demands and mineral supplies
they expect and hope the market will
respond the market is not yet responding
that is responding by terms of the
capital Investments required in hundreds
and billions and trillions of dollars of
net new mines that have to be you have
to start opening them now it takes 10 to
16 years uh to open a new mine globally
that's the average globally in the
United States it's infinite at the
moment there's no really significant new
mining happening in this country could
happen if the political uh winds change
we'll see but even if it were to happen
there's a Time problem and there's the
other Capital problem in terms of
penetration which is that it even in the
home charging Universe the for the
luxury Market where people get to charge
at home episodically that alone requires
a half trillion dollars of capital
upgrades and distribution Loops for
Transformers and wires and poles which
is not yet appropriated not being spent
doesn't mean it won't be spent but added
to the trillions of dollars that are
being allocated to other domains of the
quote energy transition I am more than
deeply skeptical that it will all happen
because it's an it's a borderline
infinite amount of money in a very short
time period calling on global markets
and refining markets to respond lastly
I'll say in terms of the and and this is
really it truly is the roadblock to EV
aspirations is materials even Elon Musk
will be held hostage ultimately to the
materials problems he's done very smart
things in tying Supply chains with
specific mines and refineries which is
way ahead of the other automakers he
makes his own electric motor which is
ahead of the other other automakers not
just his own battery he doesn't do his
own mining yet he's threatened to get
into mining I hope he does frankly
because he might Shake That industry up
but it's a long cycle industry refining
is long cycle and at the moment 50 to
80% of all the world's energy minerals
nickel Cobalt lithium copper all of them
graphite are refined in China not Min
but refined there the refineries took
them 10 to 20 years to build they're
very good at it their technology is
relatively sophisticated their costs are
low because it's a Coal Fired grid
two-thirds coal fired so the question
you'd have in your mind are two things
in terms of the aspirations to get the
world using as many EVS as the as the
optimistic forecast put out is will the
world produce enough Metals at prices
the world can afford in that time frame
the next decade
and will China never exercise pricing
power again China's market share in
refined energy minerals is double opec's
pricing power in oil to believe that
they'll never exercise pricing power
strikes me
as I'm call me skeptical I think they
probably will at some at some point they
haven't yet so all of these battery
assembly plants including Elon musks
that are outside of China will be
subject to huge uh price pressures
upwards not downwards on all the inputs
and again I'll end with this observation
electric vehicles expensive ones can be
made profitably but the battery is the
single most expensive part of the
electric vehicle it cost more than an
engine and transmission combined and its
cost is 75 to 80% determined by the
spending on the bill of materials at
today's prices so even if you took with
Automation and take a labor out of the
20% of overhead and Manufacturing you
still have materials and minerals
dominating what the price of the EV will
be in the future so it's a pure guas
frankly we don't know but I there's no
evidence in all of the history of mining
of the world certainly not the last
century of an expansion and Mining
capacities equal to what's required to
just build the number of EVS that would
constitute half of or some high
percentage of the cars on the road by
2030 thank you Mark uh 5 minutes of
summary from you
Rosario I'm going to go up here talking
up here better um okay uh so I I want to
clarify my position um I have no
animosity towards ice vehicles or the
oil and gas industry um I'm not
advocating for Banning traditional cars
or making them less accessible uh
abundant and affordable energy is
necessary for human flourishing the root
of my argument is in recognizing
emerging Technologies not in opposing
existing ones so electric vehicles are
gaining traction not because they're
being forced upon consumers but because
they offer Superior feature sets making
them increasingly desirable for a broad
population this is not about banning ice
Vehicles it's about demonstrating that
EVS are poised to dominate the free
market because they are a better choice
in many respects for many people so
reflecting on the debate we covered
technological innovation uh the economic
realities and consumer behaviors and I
think we've successfully dismantled the
resolution that electric vehicles are
not just for the elite or well healed
minority there's evidence for a
different future and I think my opponent
would agree with me that electric
vehicles are virtually an INE
inevitability not a possibility the data
is unequivocal the costs are plummeting
and accessibility is broadening EVS
specifically Teslas are becoming the
go-to Cho chice for a diverse range of
consumers not just the affluent let's
talk about Tesla's compelling Case Model
Y is a bestselling car in the US and
globally it outperforms ice vehicles on
every metric it has lower life cycle
costs Superior performance and
unparalleled convenience and autonomous
driving features that are unavailable on
any other car this isn't speculative
it's the current trajectory backed by
hard data the best business Minds on
Earth are focused on making it happen
the Catalyst for change is not
government intervention or environmental
altruism this change is driven by the
free Market's quest for efficiency
Innovation and value and the transition
stands as a tribute to competition
entrepreneurship and consumer
choice so I'll give a warning to
Skeptics ignoring the evidence is
perilous the EV Revolution is not on the
horizon it's already here the resolution
is not just flawed but it's
fundamentally at odds with the Zeitgeist
of our era by 2035 the majority of
vehicles sold will be electric not gas
guzzlers they'll be Sleek efficient and
offer unparalleled value to owners this
is not a pipe dream it's an impending
reality propelled by free market
principles if you find yourself still
clinging to the belief that you'll
always prefer an ice car for its engine
sound or nostalgic value consider the
transition from hor drawn carriages to
automobiles at the dawn of the 20th
century Hors drawn carriages were the
dominant form of of Transportation many
people couldn't fathom replacing the
natural experience and the connection
with a living being for a noisy
mechanical automobile yet as cars became
more reliable efficient and affordable
they quickly replaced carriages
relegating them to a novelty this wasn't
just a shift in technology it was Market
driven obsolescence as electric vehicles
continue to outperform ice cars in
various metrics from efficiency to
maintenance costs isn't it likely that
the same Market forces will relegate ice
cars to the pages of History perhaps
it's worth reconsidering your position
even if you're not convinced that
traditional ice cars will become
obsolete like horse drawn carriages
that's not the standard I need to meet
in this debate the real question is
simpler if you believe that electric
cars will be affordable and accessible
to more than just the wealthy by the
year 2035 then you must vote against the
resolution in some the resolution is
soundly debunked the future is electric
and it's a future that welcomes everyone
not just the wealthy the path towards
this future isn't a burden but it's an
exhilarating opportunity an opportunity
to embrace groundbreaking Innovation to
Leverage The transformative power of
technology and to forge a more
sustainable world for us all thank
[Applause]
you uh Jane uh please open the voting uh
again the resolution reads between now
and 2035 electric vehicles in the
consumer Market will disappoint
environmentalists by remaining a product
bought mainly by the well-healed
minority I have in my hand the soul
Forum Tootsie Roll that will be thrown
at the winner of this uh debate uh vote
yes no or undecided on the resolution
again uh you are all invited to the
after after party the additional reason
exciting reason to come to the
Afterparty is that at that point I will
permit Mark Mills to expound on the
virtues of the hybrid vehicle I think he
has something to say about it on a
virtuous level in fact we'll also hear
from aario you'll get a chance to talk
to these two very approachable guys not
just about hybrids but about anything
else on your mind once politics excuse
me Canadian politics Canadian they're
both Canadians by the way and so they
feel a special bond uh and uh I think
that they're not too happy with their
home country at the moment so you can
hear about that from these guys too
apart from the hybrid vehicle you can
also take advantage of the Free Fair
punch from the from the fair Liquors
group that's a kind of a tequila and
Sherry drink delicious food served by my
wife is Sako the party is two blocks up
town at 55 great Jones Street which is
basically Third Street follow me follow
a number of other people in the audience
who know where it is I'm going to escort
these two guys because I don't want them
to get lost uh these two Canadians do
not get lost in New York you'll be
coming with your wife to the party
afterwards uh to which you are all
welcome if you haven't paid for it do a
donation tomorrow or the next day uh to
defay the cost of the party well uh
while the Voting is proceeding uh I want
to announce that uh on Tuesday November
14th will be our next debate the that
resolution will read artificial
intelligence poses a threat to the
survival of humanity that must be
actively addressed by government that
resolution will be defended by Susan
Schneider and it will be opposed by job
land gree both of whom have written
books about the subject that will be a
debate on Artificial Intelligence on
Sunday December 17th we will have a
matina our second matina ever uh and
that will be a debate on the following
resolution a little bit wordy but very
much to the point the resolution reads
the making of national internet policy
was Hind
rather than helped by the July 4th
Federal Court ruling that restricted the
Biden administration's Communications
with social media
platforms that resolution will be
defended by law professor K clonic and
opposed by Jay
bataria uh as many of you know Jay
bataria was one of the plaintiffs in
that July 4th ruling so he will appear
and that will be a Sunday to 7 17 300
p.m. mattin tickets are on sale for that
one as well and uh in uh January uh we
are going to have a debate on the
following resolution what do I I see
Jane approaching me but probably the
Voting is still going on January uh uh
Monday the
29th uh the resolution will read
government must play a role in fostering
scientific and technological progress
by funding basic research the resolution
reads again that government must play a
role in fostering scientific and
technological progress by funding basic
research that resolution will be
defended by Anthony Mills of the
American Enterprise Institute and
opposed by Terrence Keeley author of the
economic laws of scientific research uh
well I see I think that uh Jane is
approaching me with the results of the
uh voting uh yes okay uh drum roll
please um yes uh that's a very good drum
roll better than okay now uh the uh the
uh the yes vote began by
40% and went up to
57% and so it picked up
17.3 points uh the no vote went from
177% that's the number to beat 17 points
the no vote went from 17 to
32 very good but that was
14.6 points somewhat less than the yes
vote therefore the tootsie rooll goes to
Mark
Mills
two two blocks up town both Debaters are
coming with us to the party afterwards
and the free drinks please follow us to
55 great Jones Street guys come with
us